je lis je suis énervé après vous parce
qu'on est pas resté avec le public après
[Applaudissements]
mais je vous dis tout moi tu mangeras la
[ __ ] moi je crève l'abcès vous êtes
vous avez fini à 20 heures on n'aurait
auriez très bien pu rester un petit peu
écho public discuter avec le public qui
s'est déplacé pour voir vos gueule de
con
vos tronches de cake et non mais sans
déconner mais ils sont tous barrés des
clés mission dès qu'on a dit c'est fini
ils ont tous mené leur micro ils sont
barrées est ce que vous trouvez ça fair
play alors des films tu n'es pas bien
sûr concerné mais je suis sûr que tu as
tu serais resté oui mais foutez de ma
gueule
non mais le public le public franchement
c'est grave on est d'accord on passe est
grave mokhtar c'est grave qu'est-ce que
vous avez voudra dire pour votre défense
alors alors offert des roses non oui oui
alors une série qui les a au fait c'est
moi qui ai offert les restes à payer une
grosse toi non merci
non mais sans rigoler non mais les mecs
qu'est ce que vous aviez d'autres
affaires puisque vous dit être ici
jusqu'à 21h15 donc qu'est-ce que vous
aviez d'autres affaires à moi je tiens à
m'excuser sincèrement mais techniquement
je suis pas parti j'étais dans les loges
on va manger des balistes haut
c'était un peu la cua d'accord merci
crever l'abcès vraiment oui moi je
trouve dommage mais c'est comme ça c'est
le jeu tout le monde a des trucs à faire
et je vais crever l'abcès vraiment
parfois les chroniqueurs il se marre un
peu trop vite chiant ouais et le tonkin
gens récupèrent leurs affaires en
coulisses avec leur téléphone ils ont
pas le temps de voir les chroniqueurs et
ils viennent aussi pour faire des photos
avec les chroniqueurs et du coup ils ont
fait 600 400 km il semble hélas ils ont
vu personne là tu peux crever
c
[Applaudissements]
vraiment tenté des parts étaient par
ailleurs moi je demande aux gens de
métier la guerre moi j'étais d'ailleurs
j'ai parlé avec des gens dehors dans la
rue
ici le débat reste ici puisque avec une
boîte est en train de parler que le
public je veux pas parler sur toi non
mais tu aurais pu prendre l'autre côté
battant ben on sait quand tu vois moi je
m'en fou jusqu'à minuit si vous faites
partie vous alors petit chat parce qu'on
nous ait ni de partir mais n'importe
quoi et vous allez partir c'est parce
qu'on voit c'est que lequel tony allait
partir parce que lui aussi a été dit et
on nous a dit noubar et signés ensuite
mais personne ne dit le baril non elle
nordine jeudi remparts je vais crever
encore un autre même si on dîne le
produit d'ordinaire il nous a dit nous
on voulait partir franchement voulait
partir les médecins indiens on la fait
pas dites nous si on part et avec
benjamin on voulait même aller au
restaurant c'est très bas sinon d'une
émission se fera pas et j'étais déjà en
train de te soucier pour dire invite
m'invite m'en reste en
effet si vous voulez je vous invite au
passage jamais été d'accord et nordine
il arrive dans la vie il a dit je me dis
tout de suite quoi qu'il arrive vous ne
partirez pas comme un proviseur il nous
a cassé le moral donc on savait qu'on
restera jusqu'à 21 h 15
mais celle ci les rues benhaim pour
votre défense et ben non moi je pense
toujours au public s'il est réussi avec
vous c est ce que vous a parlé
la mairie
alors tout non cela mais attendez je
vais aller voir des gens du public
c'est à vous étaient là hier alors c'est
au plaît madame alors oui il ya que
cyril web - est-ce que vous en parler
non on l'aimé pas est ce que ton paris
enfin l'action et nos aventures il a dit
oui a que toi est-ce que vous n'en
parlez pas ne pas parler
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est une once et elles n'ont
franchement alors qu'est ce que vous
avez à dire pour votre défense et ben
non près nous a dit cassez vous ouais
c'est ça
j'ai passé une heure avec eux avant que
je suis aussi ici pour lebron technique
vrai ou pas merci
du tout
c'est encore non à la mer est-ce que
c'est bonnet
[Rires]
qui
mais voilà et franchement c'est quoi ces
gars les
gens tiennent ce qu'il apparaît bernard
montiel et aura pas de mode aux roses
il a parlé bravo
voilà y'a que monter les voilà donc
c'est horrible